I don't know anyone who has a perfect
life nobody and I know that every single
one of us have our own personal
challenges and trials and there are days
when we wish that we didn't have to get
out of bed there are days when we just
wish we could pull the covers back up
and hibernate but we all have a choice
to make we have the choice to stay in
bed and keep the covers pulled over us
or we have a choice to move forward when
I was 14 years old
nothing special stood out about me I was
just average 14 year old getting ready
to graduate from junior high very
excited I remember going to bed one
night in a room that I shared with my
sister in a bed that I shared with my
sister I remember waking up to the voice
a strange voice saying I have a knife at
your neck don't make a sound get up and
come with me
that started a nine-month long nightmare
I remember this strange man taking me
way up into the mountains behind my home
all the while at knifepoint I mean I
remember being brought so far up into
the mountains we crossed right over the
top of the mountain and started down the
other side we were about a quarter of
the way down the other side when we came
to a grove of trees and nothing stood
out about it nothing seemed special
about it but he directed me inside this
grove of trees and I remember walking in
and I saw that part of the mountain had
been leveled out there was a tent set up
there were tarps lying on the ground
hanging up in the trees I remember
seeing a huge hole in the ground behind
the tent where they had laid logs across
the top and then thrown dirt up on top
of it but the most scary part of this
whole scene was the woman that emerged
from the tent
she brought me in and she sat me down on
a bucket where she tried to sponge bathe
me and she changed me out of my pajamas
into strange robes I grew up being very
very shy and very very self-conscious
and that was just about the most
traumatic thing I had ever had happen to
me I remember begging and pleading with
her just to let me do it myself that I
wasn't dirty that I had just showered
the night before and that I I could
change myself I didn't need her help
finally after I don't know 15 minutes
probably of begging and crying she
finally just passed me the robes I
wiggled him on she scooped up my pajamas
and she left me alone in the tent
sitting on an upturned bucket I remember
sitting there and crying and crying and
thinking of what had happened to me how
had just yesterday I had been at school
with my friends
how had just yesterday I had been at
home looking red looking forward to
graduating ready to go to high school
how had this happened how had my world
turned from day tonight and what had
happened to my family had this man gone
through my house already and murdered my
family what was going to happen to me
the only thoughts that I could think of
were gonna happen to me where he's going
to rape me and then he's going to kill
me because nobody survives being
kidnapped nobody ever comes home I have
never seen a happily ever after in a
kidnapping story every story the news
repeats it's always the same maybe it's
days later weeks later years later a
body is found but that's what happens as
I sat there crying I'm being so scared I
remember the 10th dorans it being an in
walked this man and he had changed out
of the dark clothes he had kidnapped me
in into a robe just like the one I had
on and he knelt down next to me and he
started to speak and at first I was so
caught up in my own worries and my own
fears and what had happened and what was
going to happen I couldn't even begin to
think
to listen to what he was saying finally
some part of me pulled myself together
long enough to hear him say the words
that I was now his wife I was sealed to
him and that I was supposed to perform
all wifely duties and it was time for us
to consummate our marriage now I grew up
in a very traditional home my family is
very religious I have been raised to
believe that sexual relationships are to
be within the boundaries of marriage and
that's what I had always believed that's
what I had always intended on following
and so here this man was telling me that
I was supposed to consummate our
marriage and I may have grown up in a
bit of a bubble I mean I may not have
been the most forward-thinking
fourteen-year-old in the world at the
time part of me wasn't even sure I knew
what consummate a marriage meant the
other part of me was praying and hoping
that it wasn't what I thought it was I
quickly found out exactly what it was I
remember begging and pleading and crying
and tried to come up with every reason I
possibly could to try to convince this
man to let me go to not hurt me to just
release me back to my family but nothing
I said or did made a difference I will
never forget he pulled me off the bucket
where I'd have been sitting on to the
ground where he ripped off the robe I'd
been forced to put on and he raped me on
the floor of the tent then when he was
finished he got up and he left me alone
and I will never ever forget how I felt
how broken I felt how I was beyond all
help all hope that even if someone did
find me what was the point I was useless
I was disgusting I wasn't worth saving
at that point I fell asleep thinking
those thoughts and when I woke up there
was this man kneeling over me again and
this time he had taken a thick metal
cable and had wrapped it around my ankle
and had bolted it into place so that I
couldn't run away and that moment I
started thinking of all the children
whom I'd seen on the news whose stories
always seemed to end so tragically and I
couldn't help but think they are the
lucky ones they are so lucky I wish I
could be one of those children because
no one will ever hurt them again no one
will ever make them feel like they are
worthless or that they're unloved no one
can ever do that to them again I wish
that was me and that is a brief look of
what the next nine months were very
early on I made the decision that I
wasn't going to let these two captors
win I wasn't going to let them take my
life from me I would do everything I
possibly could to survive even if that
meant out living them even if that meant
surviving for another thirty years going
through this kind of abuse everyday
thank heavens it wasn't 30 years there's
only nine months later I will never
forget the first time I saw my dad after
the police had stopped and picked picked
me up I will never forget feeling that
no matter what lay in front of me it was
gonna be okay and that nobody ever again
would be able to make me hurt the way
that these two people had made me hurt
the last nine months best feeling in the
world knowing that someone loves you
the following day my mother gave me a
piece of advice and I'd like to share it
with you because as I said we all have
trials in life we all have those times
when we don't want to get out of bed my
mom said to me Elizabeth what this man
has done to you it's terrible and there
are not words strong enough to describe
how wicked and evil he is he has stolen
nine months of your life but you will
never
get back the best punishment you could
ever give him is to be happy is to move
forward with your life because by
feeling sorry for yourself and holding
on to the past and dwelling on what's
happened to you
that's only allowing them more control
more power still more of your life away
from you so don't let that happen
justice may or may not be served
restitution may or may not be made but
don't you dare give them another second
of your life I have tried to follow that
advice every day since then I am a long
ways from following it perfectly but
then again what daughter is perfect
following her mother's advice but I know
that we all have a choice I know that
when we are faced with trials we have a
choice we can give in and surrender or
we can fight and we can move forward and
as I've been able to go out and share my
story and speak with different people I
have learned so much I have come to a
point in my life that I can say although
I would never wish it upon myself and I
certainly never would wish it upon
anyone else I'm grateful for what has
happened to me because of what it's
taught me because of that perspective
it's given me an empathy I felt for
other survivors I am grateful that I can
make a difference I'm grateful that I
can speak out and especially for victims
of sexual abuse who haven't been able to
speak out for themselves yet it is so
traumatic it is so scary coming forward
and saying I was sexually abused I was
hurt someone stole something from me but
I'll never get back but I have to tell
you it is so important to come forward
and share your stories and speak out
about it even if it's not to your
community even if it's not on a larger
scale but at least to law enforcement so
that we can stop those people that are
out there taking advantage of other
people it is so important so I have to
encourage every single one of you
when you are faced with a trial don't
give up don't surrender move forward
because you never know what you'll be
able to do with it you'll never know the
lives you'll be able to touch I am so
grateful to be here with you all today
thank you so much
[Applause]
you